next work reigned at the base of Mount
Rushmore in South Dakota as fireworks
assured in the 4th of July last night
but the coronavirus has forced many
cities to cancel or at least scale down
their 4th of July fireworks celebrations
to comply with social distancing
regulations but that doesn't mean people
won't be having their own celebrations
using backyard fireworks imported from
China Iranian Ascencio has the story
unlike years past this fourth of July
won't dazzle as bright or boom as loud
as cities cancel their firework shows
over fears normally massive crowds would
lead to new explosions of coronavirus
but the global pandemic hasn't stopped
many Americans from planning their own
fourth of July blowouts using backyard
fireworks most of which are produced
halfway around the world in factories
like this one in china's hunan province
all the fireworks in this room are gonna
make it to our showrooms for July 4th
2020 jesse jo koy is in charge of
purchasing for phantom fireworks the
Youngstown Ohio based company says it
buys at least 99% of its products from
China we spoke to Jesse while she was on
a factory tour last December before the
global pandemic started along with
social distancing how important is China
to phantoms business model back in the
United States without the manufacturing
here we don't operate without China the
industry ceases to exist and this city
Lou young bills itself is the birthplace
of fireworks more than 1,400 years ago
now over 1,000 small factories supply
the world a mostly female workforce
working in shifts makes each blinking
cloud and rocket launcher by hand before
they're packaged and shipped oh there's
so much involved in it that's been
passed on from generation to generation
that it's not easily replicated anywhere
the past year hasn't been easy for the
fireworks industry the pandemic slowed
production and demand but it's been
under threat of tariffs for longer
part of president Trump's ongoing trade
war with China but each night in Lilya
the skies above looked like a
celebration is still happening
manufacturers run quality control
explosions from the city's official
testing ground launching the same bottle
rockets and red cakes that Americans are
snapping up for their own personal July
4 parties socially distanced from
neighbors for CBS this morning Saturday
Ramey innocencio Leo Young China